today's episode is brought to you by a
beautiful place to to take your face to
Europe and I'm talking about gray block
pizza can't afford to take your family
to Europe just at least go to local
Italy you know what I'm saying
gray block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard in
Los Angeles on the way to the beach gray
block get that either ladies and
gentlemen it's time to take care of your
money protect yourself protect your life
protect your wife and you can do that
well you can't protect your wife but you
can protect everything else with a Ridge
wallet a lot of people or you know have
wallets and they don't know what their
life is gonna be like they're uncertain
you know they failed out of school bla
bla bla bla bla bla but this is
different a ridge while it is of wallet
that goes in the front of your pants in
the fornear front pockets and it carries
just really the necessities man you know
it carries the credit cards the
identification the of maybe a little bit
of money you can clip it in there but
notice none of these extra curriculars
you don't need to be carrying around you
know a little hula hoop or maybe you
know a little beavis and butthead
keychain you can change all of that and
you can change your life and you can do
that by getting a Ridge wallet it's that
front pocket carry know how to manage
your money know how to manage yourself
keep your stuff in a Ridge wallet so go
to Ridge wallet dot-com slash Theo and
use promo code Theo for 10% off that's
Ridge wallet comm slash Theo and use
promo code Theo
Ridge wallet and get that Hitler lady
and gentlemen the man that's in here
right now has been a champion and I'm
saying I think about something you're
good at
now think about being the best at it the
best this is this man he's um you know
he's an original American if you will
he's British and he is a he's a sports
caster he's he's an author I mean he's
probably one of he probably a very
violent babysitter even we're just
really happy to have him here champion
personality actor mr. Michael Bisping
you
do what about do you guys have Halloween
there in the UK Halloween in England
yeah we do but it's not like it is over
here really I mean you guys go overboard
you really really get into the Halloween
which is great I love it you know my son
super excited but you know the English
you know we're not Americans right guys
go a little bit overboard on it too much
on everything you know which is great I
love it but when you see like you know
forty seven-year-old doctors standing in
line at rowlf's discussing what they're
gonna dress up on yeah I can't help but
roll my eyes a little get a [ __ ] grip
man you got three kids at home and well
I'm gonna get always a [ __ ] scary
ghost this year am i dude get a grip
come on scary I'm gonna go as Casper
whatever sexy wizard or something yeah
well especially out here now let you see
a lot of male doctors gonna sexy wizards
as well I guess we go to different bars
that's the whole definition in this city
is a bunch of sexy widows I'm good
has it gotten uh I feel like I'm Mara
especially like you in the West Coast
you live in California yeah yeah I live
in Orange County
you know Iceland is you know an hour
outside of LA and do you feel like oh
you really I'm spilling the coffee
this thing's filling this coffee still
got the shakes I'm from the fight
exactly yeah I'm just nervous they are
really really nervous here I don't know
if we're gonna look at the judges cards
but I think he lost the first round of
that coffee right is it really no no
it's not I'm just clumsy
um but yeah in the u.s. it's like I feel
like we're getting a little bit soft
over here does it feel like because I
mean America started in England we're
just ah you know America started in
England yeah well yeah you know I mean I
guess we founded the country yeah you
know then you guys decided to do your
own thing and we've said you know have
the ball and run with it go yeah be our
guest
but it'll be bothered with the bother
ation of fighting a war across the I
know you guys get very excited about it
the war of independence yeah dude we had
a very very small outpost entire country
be like a few hundred of our soldiers in
my life do you know what have the
[ __ ] thing you were grateful bastards
yeah you guys sent the B team over I
think it's exactly
did um did do you think that America's
got is is America like softer than the
UK though because I mean I don't have an
understanding I feel like the West Coast
seems kind of soft to me like Los
Angeles yeah a lot more liberal whatever
um I don't know have you spent much time
in England no okay
I mean very similar there are similar
coaches of course there is there is you
know subtle differences you know of
course but yeah generally pretty similar
to be honest you know I I wouldn't say
was softer harder of course different
parts of the country right-o better off
or harder or poorer neighborhoods or
whatever but you know there's good and
bad rough and smooth yeah where you go
and you could really probably fistfight
a pretty strong girl up a Newcastle or
if you have been out there with you
Newcastle once for sure yeah yeah I mean
New Castle's you know that's a tough
town yeah a tough town vibrant big
hearty women running around drinking it
seem like oh yeah no for sure you know
you go out that's the thing in England
you go out on a Friday night and do the
pub crawls yeah but open Newcastle and
the north in fact everywhere in England
it's freezing cold it's certainly in the
winter yeah but those women are hardcore
they'll still go out no jacket little
tiny miniskirt tits hanging out all over
the place probably others even some of
the flabby belly
oh yeah the place blowing a gale yeah
downpour heavy rains windy as [ __ ] -
three oh don't give a [ __ ] in a line out
in holding hands in a line like one
after the next and I get that next drink
oh it's beautiful man it's like watching
the it's like watching like those
turtles that come onto the beach to have
babies in this it's you know it's like
it's almost like seeing like I write a
passage I feel like in the UK well yeah
I mean I don't be in the bridal party's
never thought oh the bridal parties like
in you the hen Do's
yeah the Hindus yeah yeah yeah they're
fun you want to stay away from them oh
it was like the Polar Express one of
them coming right at me was like nine of
them in a row for sure and probably one
had a veil on some kind of sash around
her like she's in a beauty pageant I
think what she definitely doesn't belong
in a beauty
that's all any woman that's doing that
I'm pretty sure my pretty sure my wife
didn't do that any woman that yeah yeah
stay away it's a bit much it's a little
bit much a little bit much yeah in
Halloween they're like what kind of I
feel like you guys would have real
old-fashioned cars like the plague
victims are like you know I think these
days you know American culture does tend
to you know seep into British culture
eventually right I mean we're a little
bit slow to catch on to certain things
and I feel like the Halloween vibe
everyone dress it up and all that it's
starting to catch on as I say as kids as
children we dress up yeah you know but
now not at all sir
no there's no because we're at all
because go so wizards or witches because
it doesn't do anything for us but I just
say now some people are getting a little
bit cheesy yeah and they're doing the
whole [ __ ] American Halloween party
it's an effect America is like an
infection kind of that infects the rest
of the Satan in fashion listen you tried
to get me to talk [ __ ] here no no I love
living here in America I'm a proud own
oh yeah yeah Englishmen of course but
yeah you know this is what I'm bringing
up my family oh yeah yeah and do you um
do you feel is it is it tough to have
like British tradition in your house
here in America I just feel like America
it's just kind of oh I I love being in
America to like I just like it overtakes
everything I just feel like it like it's
kind of like a hedge that just kind of
keeps growing around I'm trying to think
I mean there's not too many English
traditions really I mean we're China
what we're starting to adopt American
yeah is really like Thanksgiving that's
not a thing in England obviously but
right yeah you know who doesn't like a
good roast dinner right like Rose
Bateman all the fairness of that [ __ ]
we're doing Thanksgiving now you know
and the way my wife looks at it it's a
warm-up for Christmas right so if we're
gonna have an argument or well shit's
gonna hit the fan I could do it you
don't thanks get smooth that's cool
you have you have three children do you
have correct yeah yeah and how is it are
it do they look at you as like is it
tough to be like the man in the ring and
then the man at the house like is it
different is it a different guy no I
mean I guess I've always done it I've
always done it so all they've ever known
was you know dad as a fire I guess now
I'm retired it's a little different but
yeah they they I don't know that they
disassociate themselves well not pretty
easily really yeah yeah they don't look
at me like
they don't treat me like that certain
joy does it give me any respect
whatsoever I get a lot of viral and told
to shut the door on the way out that's
what I guess she'll really fight it
maybe she'd have a little bit more
respect yeah she's a teenage girl though
yeah I was an [ __ ] when I was 15 it's
just not at your weight class either oh
yeah exactly wise I slapped that [ __ ]
real no my weight class right yeah hey
equal opportunity yeah I agree look man
hey there's good for the goose is good
for the gander oh I'm thinking about
never you sweetheart I'm joking of
course
I'm thinking about getting a sex change
in fight maybe at about 140 against all
the women somebody's done that really
that's happened now forget the name the
Valentine Fox there was a whole
controversy about that yeah Wow yeah do
you feel like the fighting like it do
you feel like um that you know with
social media and things but I was
becoming more of like a me universe that
that that fighting has gotten softer
over the years at all have you noticed
any um I don't know anything what do you
mean by me universe like just like
everybody's more like when I was growing
up like we didn't everybody didn't have
a social media everybody was on the star
yeah everyone wasn't a saw yeah I think
generally and the UFC is a bigger
product these days it's a bigger brand
it's worldwide there's more shows it
used to be you know a handful of shows a
year yeah so they said that the the
talent pool was very small you know but
they were you know they were very tough
guys these days you're gonna film or
show so yes of course you've got
fantastic fires you got could be even
Connor yeah and on this weekend an
amazing fight here we're gonna get and
there's a lot of great fights but then
also they're gonna fill the card up
they're gonna fill the roster a little
bit so there's some guys in my humble
opinion that I think don't really
deserve to be there yeah but it is what
it is they got to put fight song and
those guys are on the under cards right
and if they're good they prove
themselves then they work the way of
them being the main card if they're not
good enough them bon voyage
right yeah that's a good point every
year the cream will rise to the top
everything gets a bit diluted especially
as it gets bigger sure exactly exactly
and that's no fault of the UFC it's just
supply and demand I guess you know yeah
and trying to find the good fighters out
there you know we have a speaking of a
good fighter I mean it's kind of a wild
term but Brendan Schaub also works out
of the local studio does he really I had
no idea
you never mentioned
yeah I think you could beat him if you
came back Brendan Schaub yeah there's a
reason why he's [ __ ] the hanging
around with you guys you know Jesus
Christ you know no disrespect to big
brown yeah you know yeah yeah look
there's a reason he isn't here today I
mean I told him I say you know really I
said listen to me in the in the building
and suddenly he got sick this morning
all right okay he said he came down with
a cold so I'm like a cold sounds in a
California yeah very convenient anyone
anytime this isn't directed at Brendan
but that's like the go-to [ __ ]
excuse that use me my one on a Monday
morning when I called in the factory to
say I'm not gonna be there yeah yeah I'm
sick you know but then I think now I'm
gonna take choose the offers where no
one get sick for one day that's a good
Monday Tuesday and [ __ ] let's take
the whole week off mini you fire them up
what's going on like Michael you don't
come in now gonna make it look
believable you like a cancer now you're
home the fundraiser
yeah see I told you it's legit dude a um
with the fight coming up with the
McGregor fight coming up this week how
do you a lot of what is your take let's
just start there ah
McGregor what do you think you'll see
listen it's one or the other and right
this isn't you know generating any
headlines by saying this either Connors
gonna knock him out or curbs gonna take
him down a maul him and either one of
those is a very realistic possibility
very realistic scenario I mean curbs are
way better wrestler the problem is he's
gotta close the distance he punch his
way into the clinch khabib isn't the
type of guy that shoots from a distance
right and generally if you do that in
MMA these days it doesn't work
did you follow what I'm saying here yeah
okay I'm just wondering where you ya
know I'm where your understanding I
started gettin anyway about probably
about five or six months ago right okay
oh it's so [ __ ] now you know it all
you're so it's new but it's um it's very
novel to me like I'm curious about why
people even want to fight but at the
same time like um you know I'm friends
with Dustin Poirier I was just texting
with him I'm coming in Justin's a great
guy you know he is he's he good yes okay
baby's gonna punch his way into the
clinch the problem is he's got
go through Conor McGregor to do that
right he's gonna get past those hands
which is very dangerous but if he can do
that and get his hands on Conor he'll
probably get him down and Maul him as I
say the danger forgo babies Conor can
punch
he's very explosive he's very fast he's
very accurate and he could knock people
out so it's a tough one is it the same
Conor that we've seen no like in Israel
because his last fight was Mayweather
Yeah right
yeah and before that was Diaz right now
before that was there Alvarez
okay is it the same Conor that's gonna
like what we're gonna send what everyone
keeps saying no it's been two years it's
been two years so what you know guys
like Conor guys like me you know not
happening right now
oh this is America's doing some tests
today do you know that this is not a
drill no this is what I saw this morning
about the thing in Hawaii did you
remember the thing in Hawaii where there
was like they said there was a missile
coming in this is not a drill no that
was on the news this morning
oh really again yeah I don't know why it
was all while there was shoot why are we
in Maui
my friend Kendall Grove is an MMA
fighter he was at my house at the time
yeah thank you sure appreciate it when
that came in his family lives in Maui he
was at my house training for a fight and
he said oh my god they saying this is
not a joke there's a nuclear bomb or
missiles about to blow up mouth he was
freaking the [ __ ] I was a joke false
alarm
somebody pushed the wrong button not
trying to laugh at your misery Kendall
but I was kind of laughing inside of
that this is hilarious brother cause I'm
joking he's got six kids
Wow well no when we found out it wasn't
right me knew it was a juggle I was very
funny well look some dad's will be happy
to be out of here singing here's a pond
missile it's a house exactly my kids
take it just leave me to you know leave
me the best ones survival of the fast
anyway where were we well so we were
talking about the fight and we're
talking about yeah that everybody talks
about like the vibe on the street the
world you know the feeling on the street
is that that McGregor has been you know
you hear all these rumors even partying
he's been juggling strippers up in like
you know penthouses which is possible
well well I mean I don't know anything
about that but that it slows you but
that that slows you down you lose a
fever you
I may be for a certain type of guy you
know but for a guy like me would it and
for a guy like Connor I don't think you
don't think it would I'm not a Conor
McGregor to use a popular a nut hugger
of Conor McGregor right a guy that goes
out there you know but I'll just be
honest the person because we have the
same manager so you know I know him the
person that I know I don't think that
would matter and then when you look at
the fact that as you said correctly his
last fight was Floyd Mayweather in going
into that fight Max Kellerman the
promoter the the common carrier he's
your guy okay he said McGregor will not
land a single punch well of course she
landed more than a single punch he
landed a lot of shots right first few
rounds you'd landed that big uppercut it
was I have around 100 round true though
severe now the point I'm making from all
this is if he can land on Floyd
Mayweather he can sure as hell land on a
khabib yeah that's a fact it's gonna be
like it landed on it's gonna be like
just storming the beaches of North and
you know it's like yeah just with his
speed I just know who knows it could be
begets him that I mean could be be 26
and old for a reason you know yeah I'm
sure he's been hit over those 26 fights
he hasn't been knocked out he's never
lost a round if he can you know if he
can get his hands on Conor it's gonna be
a very long painful night for Conor but
you don't think that there's an infant
do you feel like there's an infection of
ego that can happen that can that can
deteriorate a fighter from the inside
well that's what the press conferences
are all about that's why when you see
Connor up there and he's doing his thing
yeah okay he's a wild man he's
peacocking a bit ya know for sure he's
great at it you're trying to get in your
opponent's head that's what I do when I
used to do a press conference that talk
so much [ __ ] yeah dude confidence right
and then so they think [ __ ] didn't
this guy Manny he's not scared of
anything this guy then you talk [ __ ] I
remind them of when they've been knocked
out I'll say oh this guy choked why this
guy knocked you out put that in their
mind right and then when we square up I
look like a thug but when I get in your
face and I'm talking [ __ ] it was that
war oh he's a bit of a bit of an [ __ ]
I'm trying to win a fight I'm trying to
get a mental edge right so therefore if
you believe they think God this guy
[ __ ] I saw the look in his eye this
guy's crazy money means it that can
affect you in the fight not not with
everybody but sometimes you can have a
psychological effect to where then
you're almost beaten before the fight
even starts and then therefore you don't
commit to your shots right now
Oh if I go forward but I've got to do it
I'll close my eyes and just swing right
you know what I mean and you're done
you're done it's the same as stability
if some of the view if you're afraid of
the audience so there's somebody in the
audience like I'm like a an executive or
something you think you're afraid of and
yet you yeah you're afraid to land your
shots there you go exactly like a shot
come and be free and just do you think
do you but do you think like some
fighters you know an ego can get inside
of them and it can deteriorate them do
you feel like and I feel like that's
what they're you know that's in what
sense what do you mean like you know you
just become a champion you become and
you start to believe it so much for sure
absolute that you don't work as hard or
that you don't
oh you're an idiot if you do that they
you don't have the drive as much you
know I mean I'm not gonna name names but
yeah there's been certain people over
the years that have definitely fallen
file to that do you think but do you
think that that's what's happened with
that I think that's the energy out there
that people are saying what's happened I
don't just word on the street I'm a man
on the street yeah yeah for sure me and
you both but listen I'm telling you you
know I haven't been you know you could
have been obsessing over Conor
McGregor's Instagram page because I'm
not [ __ ] 12 years old right but you
know from what I see we're adults he's
been he's been training very hard you
know there's a lot at stake here for
Conor it's not just about the money it's
not just about winning the belt you know
there's a lot of people that say doesn't
deserve to be where he is a lot of
people that say perhaps he had an easy
run the UFC hand-picked him opponents
now he's fighting khabib so now he's
only fine for the money and the belt
he's trying to prove to everybody all
those naysay listen I am who I always
said I was yeah if he goes in there and
guess he's [ __ ] ass kicked
everyone say oh you had an easy run if
he wins then you can't deny the guy
right there's a lot of pressure there so
therefore unless you're a very stupid
person which Connor isn't is he's gonna
be working his ass right he's showing up
it's the same way sure yeah I said I
think so yeah yeah I mean what the [ __ ]
do I know I don't know I don't know what
he's doing there I think I hope but I
mean you I feel like you if you've know
him and even I mean I don't know him at
all I know I mean I've spoken to the guy
in a long time right you know so we
don't have a relationship you know but
from what I know of him he's a smart guy
what about Darren Tillman what about him
are you friends with till no no
friends I mean he's from Liverpool I'm
from kind of fascinated by him a little
bit yeah well a lot of people seem to be
you know ya know I'm he's entertaining
yeah he's entertaining yeah yeah yeah
right so I got funnier but whatever I
handed the choice to Darren he's
hilarious yeah now I not only met him a
couple of times nice guy though yeah a
nice guy a nice guy seems to be he's
young I mean I don't know him but you
know I've mam a couple times and said hi
and you know exchange pleasantries
ya got a bright future he's young like
26 27 I think so yeah when you see the
younger like these younger eyes even
though it's but you know it's not many
years um but like you know dogs age in
different years and then humans is there
fighting years that age that like do you
age and faster that's like that that's
yeah that's a good comparison I mean I
guess it all depends right you know if
you're the type of fire that goes out
there I mean you see it you know they
say I'll take one to land on you right
and it's kind of a dumb mentality as a
fighter the idea is to hit and not get
hit
fight smart you know no one wants to
take punches boobs oh I like it here I
don't mind getting hit yeah that's what
you're [ __ ] dumb okay and you're
gonna struggle when you're in your 50s
oh yeah you want to remember your kids
and your grandkids names yeah you know I
guess and you want to play be playing
charades at your own Thanksgiving you
know yeah you know you just I don't know
I place your heads at my Thanksgiving
but I mean who your family is you know
yeah I know for sure yeah so I mean it
all depends on the fire fire I mean like
a Diego Sanchez he's a great fighter to
watch very entertaining you know but I
do you know he worries a miles on the
clock does he'll worry for him he's
great and he seems fine but you know
he's got a lot of miles on the clock
yeah
Oh to answer your question a long
roundabout way it all depends on your
style of fighting do you feel like
there's any ethnicity
that is or even an age or any of those
that are like the best fighters like
I've been beaten up by black eyes and
white guys
I never been beaten up by it was the
worst beating oh you know I didn't
prefer the black guys really but this is
him you know in Louisiana any time you
get beat up it's never a fun experience
that's a good point
you know the vein so
did you ever have any like did you ever
have any like any fears like that like
oh this guy's you know from a certain
place or of a certain ethnicity and then
our scare no I didn't know
I mean I've there's no real ethnicity
really I think where one has an
advantage but no I I never I'm gonna for
all types of guys but ya know never as a
fighter you don't think like that right
fighter you gotta think that you're
gonna win right you know and and I
always did I always truly believe them a
heart of hearts and fighters they don't
think like that they don't think oh I'm
scared of this guy if that's what you
think then you're doing the wrong job
you've got to think that you're the
baddest man and you can take care of
this guy 100% now of course I didn't
always win but I always went in there
believing that really even afterwards I
still fought that [ __ ] just
caught me okay let's go again yes go
again come on you won't happen again and
then as you get a little older and then
you start and then once that edge goes
that's when you know it's time to hang
it up yeah you know yeah for sure if you
actually considered that the person
you're gonna fight is gonna beat you you
shouldn't be thinking like that you
gotta have absolute confidence and going
back to McGregor that's one of the
things that he exudes so that's what
makes him so successful as well when you
win in two so your last two fights you
know you're the last you got your career
you were losses do you sorry to break it
to you yeah yeah I had no idea in my
mind I'm still there when I thought I
found Chomp let's go locked it in our
minds and hearts you are do you did you
have did you know that it was like the
edge was starting to go or did it was it
just no no it wasn't that my edge is
still there 100% but for me I had
injuries yeah a lot of injuries I mean
I've my right eye suffered a lot without
my vision our eyes is almost
non-existent I mean out of it but not a
tiny tiny bit and like a rescue animal a
bit now and and word got out yeah I mean
everyone was talked in that side yeah so
it is what it is you know I mean I
fought for years with impaired vision
you know I feel like it was a bit cheap
like maybe they should tie one of the
wrong sort you know wear a bag the other
guy do you gonna do what you gonna do
here put a touch of the on it gonna be
[ __ ] fair
great fire and would make you burn and
let's see how well you [ __ ] do
with the NIE patch on yeah gee a wooden
box nice you wouldn't knock out Luke
Rockhold in the first round on two weeks
now it's the most wins in the UFC not a
chance
guarantee no but yeah you know for me
the reason I'm retired obviously I lost
the GSB and my wife wanted me to retire
a long time ago yeah you could see it in
her eyes a bit I was watching yesterday
I was watching when you beat Rockhold
and took the title and your family's
there in the ring and Rogen's
interviewing you and your really cool
moment man you could tell like thank you
or so I mean yeah you must does you feel
that even in your body still sometimes
that moment when I see it back when I
watch you back yeah for sure man it was
great it really was because everybody
always wrote me off throughout my career
I always believed in myself and my wife
did a team you can see that with her you
can see like if it weren't for her I
wouldn't be sitting here having this
conversation with you today
ya know so she was a big part of the
journey but what got us on to this I
never have been hit in the head too many
times but we talked no we were just
talking about um oh do you when you do
when you know it's time oh sorry that's
what was generally a furious like I'm
not like you know I'm just
I have trouble I've always had trouble
like I was always kind of afraid to
fight as a kid you know like I had to
use my words because I wasn't strong
nobody ever taught me how to like fight
or like you know defend myself as a kid
you know and so I was always a you know
a chatterbox you know I was the guy you
would probably hit first yeah yeah when
I was a kid I mean you know I mean
without going into too much detail there
was a lot of violence in our house yeah
I had a lot of brothers and my mom and
dad they were afraid to kick the [ __ ]
out of his own occasion on a daily basis
yeah and then I've been older brothers
that were [ __ ] as well oh I spent a
lot of time getting the [ __ ] kicked out
of me I could have given you a break at
least the brothers you know well you
know to keep you honest but so yeah when
I was younger I was kind of that kid
yeah always getting into scrapes then I
met my wife and she calmed me down yeah
fortunately yeah right how much how nice
is it to have like that family that
background like does that just to know
that you have a place no matter what is
going on like do you feel that now like
we're able to feel that throughout your
career
you're like in what sense you know like
if you have somebody that really cares
about you you know like to have that at
the house having somebody hold down your
home and have a home you know yeah well
I mean that's one of the the biggest
thing a fighter needs a fighter needs a
stable home life a lot of fighters if
they're if they're home scenario is in
turmoil if they've got a crazy wife if
they've got a volatile relationship if
they're young free and single and and
they're being distracted and Paulding oh
these are the directions that's not good
for a fire right the best thing a
fighter needs is a nice calm stable home
life you don't be at the gym sparring
with guys wrestling guys doing jujitsu
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of you
lifting weights powering running sprints
all that [ __ ] and then going home and
then having another five rounds with
your wife yeah you know what I mean yeah
you need a nice stable home life and if
the home life isn't right then that can
affect the fighter in the Octagon in the
boxing ring in the performances so it's
important I was always lucky yeah yeah
she does as she's [ __ ] told look I
remember all days my best the old days
used to you know you just meet a woman
anywhere and just bring her home and
that was it yeah well I mean I've never
experienced that one but okay and if you
say so buddy that might be called raping
but if she went missing it was like you
know you know she went to get water by
the spring you know maybe a wolf got her
maybe maybe those are the old days oh
yeah maybe
way from Louisiana was yeah that's how
it goes on in Louisiana yes okay all
right sounds like fun
I gotta go sometime have you got to
spend any time with that Cormier Poirier
I'm a big no of course yeah absolutely I
work with Cormier folks all the tierney
all right guy he's the best he's a
bullet yeah he tries to bully me all the
time is he really high every time wow I
was having walks in the room you would
think having two belts and being we
might need to belt he's got a bit of
girth or he's gonna very wide midsection
it's almost like he's made of like
butterscotch he's a big bear Alaska yeah
no this he's great he's also we just
bust each other's balls he seems like a
really charming guy he is he's great did
you know start to notice at some point
in your career that you were going to
that you had a knack also for
commentating and for being a personality
like did you did that start to grow in
you was it what was that like yeah I
don't know I mean it's always weird
right you sit and you watch it at home
and you think this is easy this is easy
these guys are terrible right and I
actually got a shot at doing it on Fox
and it's way harder at first once you
get used to it always it's a walk in the
park it's easy but at first you know
[ __ ] this is actually harder to do it on
cue you know to make sense but you start
to notice it in your career like I
noticed like like from my career's been
lifting up over the past year and a half
right and I put in a lot of work you
know 15 years as a comedian but I start
to notice now I'm a little bit more of a
businessman than I ever thought I was oh
just a different side of me that I
didn't know I kind of lived in me but it
started to kind of bloom but during your
fighting did you start to know that you
had enough of a personality to also do
yeah
iemon Terry yeah well for me you know I
mean as a fire as being a successful
fighter you know you get certain
opportunities yeah and you explore those
opportunities I mean for me you know I
never thought I'd be an actor you know
and that's what I'm working on these
days that's where my primary focuses and
being you know an MMA fighter I got an
opportunity to do this movie yeah and
and I'd never acted in my life didn't do
[ __ ] drama school or anything yeah
Billy Elliot brother yeah this ain't my
scene anyway but then I got a shot doing
a martial arts movie and I went and I
did it and like anything I do I try to
put my best foot forward so I did some
acting classes and stuff going into it
and I did this movie and I loved it
absolutely loved it and that kind of
developed that passion so I started
exploring that more and more and then
stuff on TV with Fox and all the rest of
it and a bit of commentary then a
podcast so I do know this type of stuff
and yeah just kind of slowly slowly
started developing into a career it was
never a conscious effort right you know
it wasn't I thought I thought one day oh
I'm gonna start trying to do a podcast
or be an actor or whatever but he just
you know you might go from there might
be six months between fights yeah you
know what I mean you go to the gym you
work out that's an hour-and-a-half what
else you gonna do with the rest you dead
yeah I like to be busy if I'm not busy I
start freaking out yeah
today I got a busy day yesterday I was a
little quiet and I'm like what am I
doing with my life
hey get away I like to be busy all the
time so I was exploring all these things
between fights and then as I say slowly
developed into a career and then I
thought you know I've been hit in the
head long enough maybe maybe I've got
enough going on to step away from the
Octagon yeah I could see that man and
also um was it hard to admit it like
Wizards somebody of were there people
that you had conversations with and that
sort of thing like I couldn't imagine
having to decide that I have to stop
doing comedy especially at a point in
your life when still physically you're
very capable and everything like that's
a that's a unique decision yeah well you
know familiar actually it was kind of a
I wouldn't say a knee-jerk reaction I
was gonna say early my wife wanted me to
retire they're not on the belt she went
when I fought in LA against Rocco she
was like babe when you that's when you
give a little bit of greenery and they
want it you know dad said that when you
win are you gonna retire I said if I
lose I'll retire if I win you ready
actually making some decent money oh
yeah [ __ ] crazy well if we were
exactly come on to Newcastle so so she
wanted me to retire then carried on had
a few more fights and then I was flying
up to New York I was gonna record the
podcast believe you made with my buddy
Luis Gomez je Gomez I better say and I
was on the plane and I'm watching a
movie called journeyman and it's a which
incidentally I auditioned for years ago
pricks never gave me the part but I'm
what very very good amateurs right none
of them know they don't know anyway I'm
watching the movie it's a very very good
movie Jim and if you get a chance and
it's about a boxer
that was a world champion and he gets
hurt in the ring and after he wins the
fight and after the fight he collapses
at home and he's got severe brain damage
and this and that and he doesn't know
what's going on he puts his baby son
inside a tumble dryer or washing because
it's making noise he's just messing up
he doesn't know what's going on yeah
it's a very emotional movie and it
pulled on my heartstrings and I thought
to myself you know this isn't worth it
you know I mean I've got you know acting
career going on I got my podcast I do a
lot of work for the UFC I got you know a
chain of gyms in the UK you have a life
I've got a lot
stuff going on and yeah I enjoy fighting
and it's a part of me it's part of who I
am it's in my DNA but you can't do it
forever forever and it's unfair to my
family to my wife to put them through
that stress when everybody knows that my
visions impaired yeah also I was like
okay maybe maybe now's the time
now what if they came out with yeah I
mean I can't even really imagine that
bro it had to be kind of like it was
actually a pretty easy decision
really yeah cuz I watched it and as I
say it actually brought a tear to my
eyes I say it's a great movie and the
actor in question one of your eyes yeah
yeah exactly yeah yeah you know but yeah
it was it was easy I thought yeah and I
agree with the this the message of this
movie Wow it struck a chord with me ah
yeah you know what now's the time at the
time and do you think like do you start
to notice then because I'm just curious
about like the spirit of fighting like
then this would it is inside of somebody
that gives them like that you know that
ability like well it depends it depends
what you're doing it for you know what I
mean like for me I left school at 16 in
England I came from a family love my mom
and dad daily but you know they work
together and you know it was a tough
environment it was it was a very very
tough environment as I said left school
at 16 went straight into dead-end jobs
working minimum wage in factories one
thing that what shitty job the shittiest
jobs I could ever [ __ ] imagine really
you name it I've done them all yeah oh
god what are you doing over there
anything and everything you know driving
a forklift working in a slaughterhouse
[ __ ] rocking furniture you know not
door-to-door sales yeah double glazing
no double glazing windows doughnuts yeah
you have much more success selling
double glazed doughnut to me yeah yeah
yeah exactly you're right yeah no double
glazed windows whatever solves a lot of
them it's not like a scam is it do you
know he's like modern windows you know
double glazed windows so what were you
guys using before that just [ __ ] the
single single glazed no everyone else
double glazed windows you probably have
double glazed windows and anyway so he's
trying to get people to do that and I
was never selling much yeah I didn't
think we were selling like Oprah so back
then I was way
bigger way bigger yeah and I had a
shaved head and you know I yeah and I
was at and my boss was like you're not
selling very much Michael I'm like yeah
it's like you think you mean a bit
intimidating at the door because you're
a pretty loud big person I'm like no I
don't think he's gonna buy a glass
window
yeah sign up so anyway yeah I did you
know all these shitty jobs and then you
know I'd met my wife and we had two kids
and I was working as a quality control
inspector at a furniture store Furniture
Factory and my boss there a great guy
nice guy very intelligent and we would
chat away and he used to say to me say
Michael you're a smart kid is this what
you want to do for the rest of your life
well I was like [ __ ] no he said I'll
ever think about what you want to do
have a thing and then come back to me
and talk to me because you don't wanna
do this for us to your life I'm like
yeah no anyway a few days passed so
there was always some guy not too
energetic like you're not pleased but
I'm curious about this so it was like
somebody it was actually a guy who's
yeah after you and said it was a guy he
was my Foreman it were and you really
trusted this guy yeah I looked up to him
yes yeah yeah it was a nice guy you know
interesting how when you're young
especially if you're a young man like
you know I didn't have like a lot of
like father figures anything like that
around so any man that would give me
like attention or like so actual
interest you know that wasn't a damn PDF
file or someone if you have those in
your country but no unfortunately we do
I think they are universally okay round
we doesn't make them fighting yeah yeah
100% I'd buy that paper
I'm sanction that one dude I call me
Kellerman in that one bro yeah yeah what
Sam but um but so I can just imagine
like the effect that that has like when
some guy like shows you interest in his
like here have a think about what you
want to do it really resonated with you
yeah for me I was always had an I always
had a problem with authority figures
right always that kid I had too much to
say I was a loudmouth I was always
getting in trouble you know I was an
idiot I was it was a dick you know and
this guy he knew how to speak to me he
was a nice guy and he and he said that
to me said you think about what you want
to do and fortunately the job didn't
require much brain power so I it gave me
a lot of time to think and I thought
about it and I went up to him one day
I said make I've decided what I want to
do and he put down his clipboard and he
came off when he's like what is he and
he thought I was gonna say okay so I'm
gonna go to school I'm gonna study to be
this that and the other and I said and
this is 2003 I said I'm gonna be a
professional fire and he was like oh my
god I thought you were smart I thought
what do you mean you're gonna be a
professional fire I might make I should
do a lot of martial arts okay and he's
looking at me like what are you talking
about what is this I think I gave this
[ __ ] three weeks to think about that
and I'm like no seriously me trust me I
was very good and I brought in this
whole kickboxing video of me keep boxing
he's like oh yeah all right you know
they said that was just fueled of
aggression the guy sucked yeah I know
but you know anyway so we're so yeah
quit work I moved to another city
started training and the rest is history
Wow yes how I got into it so but now
there's another thing inside of you do
you notice that whatever there's
something inside of a fighter or
something inside of someone who who who
wants to fight do you notice any of
whatever that energy or that vibe is
that transfers that's still in you but
you notice it goes into other things in
your life now like well I'm still very
ambitious right you know and that's
where it came from for me I wanted to 5
because yeah that's what I'm trying to
get my children a better life right you
know to me I was sick of just scraping
by you know what I mean living paycheck
to paycheck still having to borrow money
off my mom and dad and they didn't have
any money
my mom disabled she had polio as a kid
you can hardly walk she's got no money
on her own yeah I said I was able to go
to her and say mom let me five quid so I
can put some petrol in the car so I can
get to work you know and it's just sick
a living life like that and all that
[ __ ] this you know I want better and I
want my children to have better yeah so
that's why I started fighting and now
the same the same ambitions no because
I'm not fighting anymore right but now
it's even harder because now that
spoiled little bastards have got
accustomed to a lifestyle and I'm gonna
keep the minute you know what a Mumma
wives like we gotta get a brand new
Range Rover soon I'm like [ __ ] Dana I
need a fight yeah no I'm joking but no
he's like some son needs braces like I'm
not gonna stray [ __ ] so so yeah so you
know that the
Bishamon the fire's still very much very
so do you see so looking back now do you
think that it was do you think that the
thing that fueled you to fight was
actually ambition or was this money it
was money 100% right one milk that was
the reason it was to make money yeah and
I remember at the time the sport it was
a niche sport you know nobody knew what
MMA was in England yeah probably 2003
not many people in America did Oh a lot
of people still think if you say I'm
getting into MMA they think it's
homosexuality yeah
no no you know maybe bring the job what
it's wrestling no but but nobody knew
back then right it seemed crazy it
seemed like I was having delusions of
grandeur I know that a lot of people
like around people think you're crazy
well Peter said I was being very selfish
as well really I know I know some
friends came to me said Michael you've
got two children what are you doing and
I'm like I'm trying to give them a
[ __ ] life and their way yeah but
you're gonna quit work you're gonna move
to another city and you're like I'm
watching [ __ ] Cinderella man on my
phone right now all right will you give
me a write in the elements great and did
it for me
Oh bro brought me to tears dude anytime
I need a movie or what's in a role when
I don't flew out [ __ ] max baer bro with
within ya [ __ ] him
within what was it like 14 months of
making that decision I was flying over
to Las Vegas for the Ultimate Fighter
Trials and I watched Cinderella Man on
the on the play and I was like oh I'm a
mate that was really like crying I'm
like no no she's just got something in
my eye like emotion you love bastard
leave me alone a fairly airplane movies
like it I was crying an aeroplane I
don't know what it is but it gets me
every time
sons of [ __ ] I get really into it
yeah would you would there be any fight
that you would come back out for do you
think er not really no I mean do I miss
it of course I mean I loved it it was a
fantastic phase of my life and had some
amazing experiences travelled the world
and you know I I joke I speak to Jason
Perillo I'm a boxing coach all the time
I just text him the other day I you know
he said how you doing I said [ __ ]
regular life is boring oh is that that's
why I drink
I said yeah me too I said [ __ ] I'm doing
this hole so October [ __ ] oh yes
he's only the first October so [ __ ] it
you know so that never lasted yeah
Rogen's got a gun infected with this
bull yeah yeah bollocks Michael I said
this to my coach - Perillo
and he said it's like French Frank
Sinatra said it's in one so you wake up
you don't smoke you don't don't drink
you wake up in the morning that's the
best you gonna feel all day yeah you're
right I'm getting a bottle of wine
they're like I'm gonna do something yeah
it's noon I'm drinking in a parking lot
yeah oh do they have a lot of like in
the US everything like I feel like it
becomes like a problem you know and like
I you know a lot of our audience is like
you know young dudes that struggle with
stuff and having problems right which is
which is great because I've been one of
those guys in my life and it's like it's
nice to be able to talk and share it's
nice to be able to hear you know from a
guy who you know wanted to make his life
better and saw an opportunity of
fighting you know over furniture for
sure yeah well the song is I mean I
always say this and and I do believe
this I used to like going at my friend
Jacko he lives in Australia now I should
go on you know could he say to me it's
easy for you Michael you can find you
can find I said no it wasn't that easy
it took me a long time to sit and do a
lot of soul-searching everyone has a
talent it was good at something right
right and you but you got to figure out
what that is and you got to be realistic
with what that is and once you figure
out what that talent is and what you're
best at then you think right what can I
do with that talent and where could it
take me what's a possible career path
but what are the steps that I need to
take to put that into motion you know
right no one starts at the top I didn't
start in the [ __ ] UFC first fight was
for nothing my first pro fight and get
paid a penny in some shitty Sports Hall
in the middle of nowhere but that's
that's that's the groundwork that's what
you got to do right you know and whether
it's fighting whether it's being a
comedian
whether graphic design whatever it is
someone everyone has a talent you just
got to figure out what that is harness
that work on it and and and put in that
work and be hard-nosed about it right
like that yeah I never want to do that a
lot of time they don't they don't they
want the show goes over this doesn't
work they want the show they just want
the finish they well that's not how it
works that's not nobody that's
successful you know I mean I don't know
maybe there's one or two examples but
nobody walks right into it
maybe Jesus Christ only there you go
he's God was his dad he's the superstar
born into the family he was born into it
he had it easy get a leg up in life was
it now this is super interesting man
because like to act to sit and ask
yourself like what is it that I'm good
at and then where do I want to go with
it and then the steps how do I get there
yep
it's really a simple plan what it is but
it took me a long time but I was
fighting gen and that's what I was known
for even in like where I was I was known
as being a bit of a tough kid right a
tearaway you know but still it took me a
long time it was it crazy too that when
you first thought like oh it's fighting
was that crazed you cuz that sounds
crazy and I know when I quit that work
yeah and I was telling everyone on the
shop floor ordeals loud sunlight yeah
I'm moving that's nothing I'm gonna be a
professional fired they're all up there
all I know what they were all talking
about me behind my back my friends in my
hometown we're talking about me behind
my back right because a couple of others
would come up and tell me [ __ ] staring
bastards that they were such and such
she was saying you know you're living in
a dream where you're abandoning your
kids I'm like shut the [ __ ] up you know
but get on the line brother yeah yeah
beef Jerky's cries way to go throw them
into a booking my wife no but yeah there
was a lot of that you know but that's it
was never easy for anyone well you're
gonna take a chance right and like I
said to my dad he came up down to my
house to talk to me about it the my dad
was always very supportive throughout my
entire martial arts career when I was a
kid he used to drive me all over the
country he driving down to Nottingham
which from where I was from is about a
two and a half hour drive there
Nottingham from Robin Hood that's the
same yes yeah yeah that's cool yeah yeah
drive me down there on a Wednesday on a
Sunday five hour round trip for an hour
and a half for training to get the best
training you know oh wow and he was
really into what supporting you or was
he really into the fighting he was
really into sports he's really into
children even sports it was it do
whatever he could to support us and my
dad you know again partly the reason why
I do this today is because my daddy was
always very supportive in that side of
things and he came to see me and he said
well what are you doing I said well I
don't wanna be that guy sitting there
4050 years old at a bar saying I wish
I'd have done this
yeah so you gotta take a chance you know
and guess what those shitty dead-end
jobs yeah this
them you can get they'll still be
they'll still be this people still need
[ __ ] seti's put on the back of her
yeah Laurie or bacon
yeah or whatever us if you're working at
a bacon place I used to clean out
wishing wells do you know people throw
money in a wishing well I know you don't
think somebody's got to get in here
[ __ ] clean them out right so because
most people just throw garbage and
recyclers I found bloody weapons in
there I sorta just leave the money down
there oh no really
put them in your pocket oh I took what I
could yeah exactly but you know when
you're exactly being obvious yeah well
it's hard to climb back well silver ones
if you got money but I used to work in a
squatter house I was a slaughter man
yeah that's all I'm saying about the
bacon what kind of stuff you guys
killing in there sheep and cow I don't
really want to get into because you know
in this modern day and age you have a
lot of vegans out there yeah but still
dude I'm not proud of I'm an animal
lover but but yeah so I was doing a lot
of [ __ ] and would you fight him to knock
him out of what would you do well that
wouldn't be a smart idea cuz honestly I
know you might drive past them and see
them in a field the cows are big [ __ ]
creepy yeah and they're big yeah yeah I
wouldn't advise that no dude I saw a cow
get hit by lightning one time absolutely
unbelievable I saw a Doberman jump out
of a truck on you saw a cow get hit by a
line hit by like what happened totally
fine no no it's loud it's it's innards
literally shot out of its sides like in
straight lines dude they busted a man's
hiding he had killed an animal it was
hiding from the police inside of its
body one time on the out again he had
cut into an animal right starwars
like oh yeah I guess like hit inside the
cow and hid inside the cow's body is
creative I guess yeah
and it took him a while to find him too
so it gets pretty good I when I was a
kid I was getting chased off the cops
and I let on top of a wall I thought it
was a good hiding place at the time I
guess when you I'm talking about when I
was like 12 kg doesn't climbing over
garden fence and I fell on the wall and
the cop walked up with the toys Jesus
what are you doing I can see yeah am i
[ __ ] yeah I guess it wasn't the best
hiding place so not good at
hide-and-seek at least you narrow down
your sport yeah but you know there was a
cow around yeah the hot I've been out of
it
get in there we have some great calls
that came in from some of our listeners
so okay
videos and audio so put on these
headphones if you yeah absolutely
whenever and here iced tea
hey what's up Theo this is got rocker I
have a question for Michael Bisping
recently he had a situation where his
daughter threw a party at their house
and the young man who stole stuff from
the house
[Music]
Michael seemed to have a lot of
compassion for the guy even though the
guys stole stuff from his house my
question basically is did he get in
trouble as they used to make it where he
wants to give people second chances yeah
you a second chance guy when it comes to
the kids yeah for sure
obviously you listen to my podcast yeah
my door I had some friends over and we
were out of town and her friends invited
some other friends and some all the kids
ended up showing up and some little [ __ ]
stole all my watch he stole jewelry of
my wife's jewelry shed on on our wedding
day and stuff like that so yeah well I
obviously wasn't the brave kid [ __ ]
[ __ ] so I got him on the phone and
he's talking [ __ ] to me down the phone
know is that you're through to the main
man and all this I'm like dude listen
you were man enough to take my stuff I
don't want to call the cops I don't want
I don't want you to get a criminal
record you know you you're a kid you've
made a mistake you're a [ __ ] idiot
come back to my house I'm in my stuff
back and I wanted to talk to the kid and
give him some advice you know what I
mean because yeah when I was a kid out
you know I was bit of a tearaway yeah a
lot of [ __ ] I regret and it was easier
to do back then too I think things were
a little bit more erroneous back yeah
maybe maybe in that day and age but but
yeah he didn't say it my advice it was
he didn't come back no I didn't he was
an [ __ ]
he talks a lot of [ __ ] and then he got
his mom involved some reason or whatever
what at REI yeah real tough guy yeah
yeah big hard guy gets his mom to fight
his battles eventually did you get it's
like the French man I can't stand the
French I've never been a big fan oh did
you I mean the French get a hard rap and
the French in the English don't
necessarily have the best relationship
but I
I don't have much against a friend
really nah the French brother afraid I
mean my sister's is she engaged I don't
know why she she's with a Frenchman who
isn't with a friend she's with the
parchment Oliver great guy yes guy
doesn't say much
yeah but you know what their own every
now and then one sneaks over into
goodness you know into the good side you
harp at the French I just I've always
had a tough time with him I mean I do
like the movie ratatouille honor if
you've seen that it's classic you know I
have it right there watch it every day
what I did every day what about brick
Bridges of Madison County I want to go
over some tearjerkers with Evy see what
he's not I have no idea Clint Eastwood
minutes an early Clint Eastwood milf
Meryl Streep okay I like a better Clint
Eastwood do you Oh horse I mean with the
mrs. man watch with me what's it called
Bridges of Madison County
okay yeah - Amon oh man you'll love it
very quickly did you get the stuff back
yeah we got most of it we didn't get my
wife's jewelry from the wedding day and
he took some purses and [ __ ] like that
but now whatever and we went to the cops
well my wife went to the cops I didn't
want to go to the cops or my you know
but yeah she was pissed off about the
wedding stuff I'm sure very sentimental
I said well listen babe whatever you
want to do I'll support you so she went
to the cops
cops didn't do a damn thing man ever
there you go
I miss the old days and that's it
speaking of Clint Eastwood it'd be nice
if you go back in the old days and
handle it yourself once upon a time and
I've had a thought like that but not
these days I'm a bit of a pussycat these
days if I'm honest really but when I was
a kid for sure does yeah drink your milk
out of a bowl or yeah I'm not drinking
milk out of a ball I don't know what
what that would I think British Isles
finishing move I think in the who's been
the jockey finish your fire no I'm
joking
um ah he's gonna be so angry but we have
a new podcast we're starting off soon
called the King in the stings oh nice
no I'm good very good I'm happy to work
with Musa uh he's a tough guy man he's
going through a lot of different things
in his own life just getting out of
different stuff football fight or and
now in the business you know I mean he
doesn't give up anyway he's ambitious
yeah I could for him um did you have any
extra fight any extra fight questions
before we got to any other calls they'll
come to me okay I got another call
you know Tyler in Florida just give me a
call got a question for Michael
account visiting on the podcast we talk
a lot about the dark arts boy I was
wondering you know with his history if
he's ever come across a couple of times
when somebody's telling me drinking too
many babies couple a couple too many
puppets if you ever had a moment during
his fight career where maybe he was
drinking a little too much but it's not
your ear it in now have a good one gang
gang gang gang man a little too much
Pimm's you've read too much Pimm's over
there no no not too much pens beer I
mean know for sure for sure yeah so so
here's the thing and I think it's a it's
a common misconception because I had
that GSP press conference where I showed
up and I was hungover
you know what I mean and a lot of people
kind of think that you know that's how I
go through my life all the time I'm not
a heavy drinker I'm not but I was in
Vegas and GSP didn't want to fight for
like nine [ __ ] months until his balls
got big enough very French very friend
now that's not the shine off on that and
I was like I'm in Vegas I'm not fighting
for nine months I'm a grown-ass man what
do people do in Vegas I was with my
manager me ended up having a few drinks
and then you have a few drinks there the
senses get a bit slurred and you know
you make some bad decision too much like
you know you're Scottish yeah exactly
sorry so I showed up and they made a big
thing out of that and I just owned their
you know I wasn't gonna deny it like a
little schoolboy no I wasn't drinking
yes so what I'm in Vegas shut the [ __ ]
off yeah you know and so now everybody I
think they want you to be the drinker
yeah I guess but when I was training for
a fire was very very disciplined very
day of course you know I'm one of the
boys you know that's how I grew up and
after a fire our party and if I win a
fight I'm celebrating if I lose the
fight I'm John and my sorrows I'm still
gonna enjoy myself
yeah people are flown in from all over
the world you know I'm not gonna be a
little diva go well I lost my phone I'm
gonna be in my hotel room yeah I don't
talk to me yeah I'm like no these guys
have come out here to support me so [ __ ]
it we're not lose you know we're gonna
go out and enjoy ourselves and have a
great time you know and that we'll never
forget
but ya know I'm not a heavy drinker yeah
and I think people want I think it's
sometimes people hear one thing and then
they want you to be there yeah well I
want you to be the guy that goes
straight from the pub to the to the ring
you know yeah well I mean that's not a
it's not realistic yeah well you would
it be successful yeah
you know I mean yeah of course how
technical is it in the ring technical
yeah very technical but you know it took
me a long time to figure out that this
is the most important thing physically I
was always very good and I was always
able you know to overpower people or
whatever and against 95% of the fighters
out there that'll work if you're good
enough and you can get by on your
physical attributes but they're truly
elite the best fighters you know you
won't be the best of the best like that
like I usually try and get into the most
worked up stair could I just try to
psych myself up in my hotel I say my in
my locker room you know every time when
I fight I always go and close my eyes
find a quiet corner I think about the
road of being on and I think about the
journey of being on all the sacrifices
I've made and how I've made it to this
point and if I've made it this far then
I can make it one one more step I
overcame that first fight for no money
in the middle of nowhere yeah and the
goalposts move every time every time I'm
you know I think about that but then I
used to kick off amazing and now you
should think right now I'm gonna work
myself up and get in an angry state of
mind but my my coach Jason Perillo that
I work for that with for the last few
years out here he taught me that that's
not the way to be you know the great
fighters aren't like that and if you
think about it if you're in a frantic
state of mind you know the best version
of yourself for anything right whether
you're a comedian whether you're working
as a technician whether you just
whatever you're doing if you're pissed
off yeah how are you good how are you
getting your best foot forward you're
not and the same goes in fighting even
more so in fighting when you're
competing against a world-class opponent
is trying to take your [ __ ] head off
you don't be all angry and emotional
that doesn't help you want to be cool
calm collected in the moment reading
seeing everything nice and calm clear
head and it took me a long time to
figure that out
can you no no that's interesting looks
like yeah it just goes back to like
never take action when you're angry it's
like 100 percent it could be anything
whether you're sending an email or
whether you're about to compete in
something do you know could you notice
if you got another ring you're like damn
I'm a bit off skew this time of it well
I mean as I say I used to try and make
myself be lighter right and towards the
end I mean you know I hate to keep going
on about when I won the bout against
Luke Rockhold you could see how calm my
state of mind was when I walked into the
ring
and we went up and you know you got to
try I think everyone was happy to see
Luke Rockhold yeah I think they were but
we went to church gloves and he's like
no no I said no touch no touch I said
I'll touch you in a second mother and
that's just an example of it that was so
calm you know to be able to crack a joke
right witty
no touching a sec okay and I walk back
smiling and [ __ ] you know what I mean
and then I had the best performance of
my life right
you know it's what just helps on an
every level I mean as you said you never
want to send an email or respond to
anything if you're angry take him in it
take some deep breaths and then you'll
be fast so not that bad yeah take a step
back from it all take some deep breaths
whatever it is anything it really isn't
you know it really really isn't man
unless it really is and then you're
[ __ ]
taking a deep breath if you're dying
especially if you're drowning yeah yeah
yeah don't take a deep breath do not
take a deep breath yeah what do you have
Nick so I did think of one I read
someplace that you started and this
could be [ __ ] jiu-jitsu when you
were 8 years old yeah what was the level
how did you get into that here about it
and what was the level of training in
jiu-jitsu in like the late 80s in
England yes so so when I say jujitsu I
mean Japanese jujitsu so Japanese
jujitsu is the the oldest first ever
martial art and all of the martial arts
were taken from it right
judo took the throws and and made them
better karate took the striking and
heightened it Japanese so Brazilian
jiu-jitsu took the groundwork the
submission side of things and obviously
made it way better and in Japanese
jiu-jitsu as I say you do everything and
you do a lot of weapons training
nunchakus swords all that [ __ ] you do
everything you numb chucking out there
yeah a little bit a little bit you know
hit myself in the head more than I'll go
you know but so I loved it I was
obsessed with that but it was very
different it was Japanese jiu-jitsu but
realistically Japanese jiu-jitsu was
mixed martial arts but it just was that
term didn't exist you know so in like in
like 92 I was doing what we called knock
down sport Budo you can find footage of
it online if you google it you can find
footage of me as a young kid Rudo be you
do be you do knock down sport but ksb oh
wow putting Michael Bisping KS video you
see me I'm like 14 or something taking
on grown man
and burn ocol you know but we didn't
know it was mixed martial arts that
didn't X that term didn't exist right
I'm gonna have like four or five fights
in one night you know but that was I was
training Japanese jiu-jitsu but it was
everything in there so why would you
ever do a tag team okay here we go
there's me on the right a little bit
stands he shoots so old school look at
the pants this is not the most
impressive one there's better ones but
again let's see it it's you on the right
yeah hole is it another yeah that's mean
with the dark red oh there was no head
choice because we were bare fist but it
always gets me down and up on top
there's another one if you want to see
that with the one I don't work that one
there watch this you'll laugh your head
off at this this shows I was always an
[ __ ]
maybe skip forward to the start here we
go watch with me I'll go back a little
now forget it whatever whatever it
starts and I just kick the guy
immediately really hey go to shake hands
enough do I kick him out of his be yeah
but dude the referee said start you know
I'm sorry my bad he goes whoa whoa see
ya what uh let's go to a couple question
under you gotta get out of here soon
yeah I'm actually okay you're doing okay
you're okay yeah we're okay I'm okay
okay fun
yeah thank you good man I had another
one actually so the eye injury
originally happened with Vitor yes yes
did you ever think about after he got
popped for steroids like any type of
litigious things cuz I mean he [ __ ]
your career yeah
you can't think like that at the end of
the day you step in there you know we
know what was signing up for you know
yeah it was on steroids he was on TRT
was on all kinds of [ __ ] but it is what
it is you signed up for these things you
know have you seen him since and looked
him in the eyes I don't think I have
actually you know we've talked a bit of
[ __ ] back and forth on line yeah I'm not
I'm not keen on Vitor Belfort so yeah I
got a detached retina in that fire and I
didn't know it took a long time before I
even realized and the first start
getting symptoms when I was in
restaurants when it was dark lighting
I've been a restaurant and I'd have my
hand here I'd be like I couldn't see my
fingers why should I be able to see my
hand oh yeah I know this went on for a
while and it got to a point where I
Muhammad
here and I couldn't see my fingers so I
looked it up online I need any you know
signs pointed to a detached retina so I
called up this doctor that turned out to
be very close by I said huh yeah I said
I think I've got a detached retina he
said why do you say that and I told him
is that [ __ ] you need to get in there
ASAP so I went in they repaired that I
had a surgery they repaired the detached
retina I was training for my next fight
which was going to be against mark Muniz
and I'd done some press in LA and I'm
driving back and then if you imagine
curtains closing on a window and then
just the curls not quite closed and a
little bit in the middle that's all I
could see I had a black curtain either
side and a little bit vision down the
middle
oh [ __ ] so I called my eye doctor next
day we did surgery again they said what
happened was I was very unlucky it just
happens sometimes
scar tissue developed on the retina and
it causes the retina to read attached so
that read attached they repaired it and
then I got glaucoma I was walking is the
worst day of my last senior citizens did
yeah yeah yeah exactly
normally I'm walking the dog and I start
getting a headache and I I get back to
my house 20 minutes later and the
headache so bad I'm laying face down on
the floor just facing the fort screaming
the head it was so bad so where my wife
calls my eye doctor she says he says I'm
in surgery right now go to this other
doctor she gives us a number we have
down to see him and they checked the
pressure in your eye so your eye is if
you touches wet there's moisture in
there which is constantly going in to
keep the eye wet and there's a drain in
there so the water comes out so it's a
constant cycle of fresh water or some
kind of liquid yeah if it's fresh water
for all those doctors looking at me
saying this guy's our [ __ ] you know I'm
sure it's not fresh water that we drink
but you get what I'm saying yeah I ain't
doing surgery yeah so anyway so that
that drain was blocked yeah so it's like
a balloon on the end of a tap if you're
filling it with water what's gonna
happen it's gonna pop it's gonna pop
that's what glaucoma is so I went in
there and they checked the pressure on
my eye and a normal person's pressures
between nine and 20 oh well and mine was
like 97 or something it was like 48 psi
they were like that's the highest we've
ever seen to go to this other Hospital
so I went there they tried to clear the
blockage with a laser and then they give
me some pills to go home so I went
I'm still in pain these pills are making
me drowsy affecting the pain a little
bit I'm letting bad and I'm still uh
screaming in pain it's like two o'clock
in the morning I'm still doing this my
wife sighs I'm calling you I'm supposed
to be better by now oh of course
the symptoms started like 9 o'clock in
the morning focal now super o'clock yeah
[ __ ] those lasers so my doctor calls my
wife calls mad doctor and he's like
blown away that I'm still in pain so we
went to Pasadena they did an emergency
surgery that kind of [ __ ] up
when I came around there too we undo the
showed you redo it again so yeah I just
got really unlucky with the I got bad
luck in it I just got bad luck man what
are you gonna do you have an excellent
now is that the fighter who would the
heals like an image where it's like his
one of like his his his logo images like
the is he's talking about DNA yeah you
doing what Dan Henderson oh yeah is that
guy gonna go there Bob are you gonna go
there oh we gonna bring that up okay
let's talk about every time you've been
knocked out let's talk about this guy's
image where he's floating above your
unconscious body about to land another
well what do you think about Michael
anything I think he was he was about to
bring it back how you got that one back
and then ended up beating yes no I knew
that isn't where he was going but you
know okay it's okay throw shade it's
fine I can take yeah I can take you look
let's not the one with the [ __ ]
mullet look let's just make fun of
pretty shocked oh no I don't I don't um
no and we don't have to put that part
yeah you know like you could I don't
give a [ __ ] okay edit out anything out
where he mentioned me being knocked out
no I mean I I don't love his fun song
real quick
that's the guy who used a logo from that
punch yeah it is what it is good for him
god bless him you know oh it is you're
just dirt though nice part of history
like people always mention that to me
the cell does it bother you when
somebody mentions that your losses or
whatever like no does it feel a little
bit cuckoo like to be able to say you
know to take that hit and now you're
you're still alive you're still function
you're still killing it
does it make you feel a little like a
slide champ that fight happened at UFC
100 right and I went into it I talked a
lot of [ __ ] you know as I always do
trying to sell the fight and generate
interest and yeah I got knocked out in
the second round on like the
most-watched UFC event ever so you know
it was bad luck but for me it was part
of history it was part of my journeys
yeah made me who I am I went away from
that and I became a better fire I
learned more about myself I mean when
you're kicking ass and you're winning
fights all the time that's great and
that's what you want to do you don't
really learn much about yourself when
when you get knocked out when you lose
badly like that you know it takes a lot
to come back I remember Joe Rogan saying
Michael Bisping is done you know
fighters don't come back from knockouts
like that you know I'm the fact I did
come back and then I came back strong
and you don't become the champion I was
proud of myself so for me there's no
shame there whatsoever it's part of the
journey it's part of the journey it's
part of history yeah you know being a
little [ __ ] about it isn't gonna change
anything you know I embrace it you know
I'm proud of it I'm proud of every one
of my fights win or loss you know so
that's just a fight that you could go
back in time that you wish that you
would do that you is there one that
stakes I said it sticks out of your head
and I could do differently or just that
you could do that you could do again and
no matter the outcome ah well yeah I
mean you know knocking out Luke Rockhold
in the first round I could do that every
day I'm a liar I think a lot of people
that was fun the GSP fight I wish I
could redo that one again that was a
going into that when I had the best
training camp of my life and it sounds
braggadocious but my knockout power was
out I put a few guys to sleep in the
training camp not meaning to do it so if
I had the best camp and then the final
white they were calling and the final
day of training I [ __ ] tear all the
cartilage in my ribs I get taken down
this guy like his life depended on it
land on the floor and I knew instantly I
just felt the rip and the pain was
excruciating I spent all week icing it
and getting massaged in all this I could
have moved to well but you know I was
gonna pull out the fight again as a
fighter you think you can still win
right yeah so what I got an injury you
know but it is busy in your story like
in your story a little some turmoil is
not gonna shut down the car weight it is
what it is yeah you know you still gonna
turn up a fight you know yet is it
perfect
right
especially look even in your own history
like for you like a bump in the road is
a that's how the road is exactly that's
just the way it goes this is the cut
this the hand we're dealt
yeah still gonna play still gonna stay
at the table and play my hand you know
what I mean
yeah I love that attitude man so many
people does don't even have that
attitude anymore that we just we I feel
like a lot of times rested in such a
crybaby culture where nobody's just like
this is what it is let's move forward
like who knows not for sure absolutely
you know I mean life isn't perfect yeah
you know and again whether it's fighting
or whatever it is you're gonna play with
the hand that you've been dealt you know
the most of it do the best you can you
know so yeah I guess I've always been
like that
yeah that's a great I mean it's just
such a it's a nice disposition half
because the opposite of that is this you
know is getting too much caught on this
whining kind of you know pointing
fingers and blaming universe you just
kind of like put I hate that suit I
really do you know I mean I don't want
to get into all but the way the world is
these days you know it pisses me off you
know I'm glad I grew up in the northwest
of England in the 80s yeah because I
think in this day and age with these
cell phones and all the rest of it I'd
be [ __ ] yeah you definitely would
probably have charges pending I probably
yeah yeah but no I think but I also
think that the news makes things a lot
worse and things are I think that people
and life is better than actually that's
what the news do they sensational eyes
everything to try and make it as bad as
possible because that's what sells on
the urgently doom and gloom people are
attracted to it's like a car crash you
know it's terrible you know it's tragic
but you got a look at it and that's what
the new cell every day they're
sensationalized everything unfortunately
still turn the news on because you want
to know what's happening in the world
yeah but you see in the worst sector of
society you seen everything that's
happened bad amplified by 10 because
they want to make it sensational they
want to sell they want people to watch
yeah you know so we're gonna be careful
where you get your news we got to be
careful you get your news from agreed
what do you watch is there a show that
you watch are you and the missus watch
at the house right now what am I
watching
Ozark oh yeah Oscar day I'm liking that
yeah a little bit of low-key murder a
lot of people died in that show for a
small town I'm surprised more isn't
going on there's a lot of people popping
up that in that in that show do
from like one of the first in our
neighborhood like people used to have
when a dog would have babies people
would get out and bet on how many babies
the dog okay I have so you to have these
[ __ ] people out there just bidding on
like I got five I got seven so people
were just bet on how many it was just
kind of like it was kind of the same
sort of environment as Ozark a little
bit right okay yeah that sounds like
just a little bit rural and kind of
ridiculous you know if you were knows
are which would you be you be that that
one family I mean one family yeah the
family with the blonde girl with the
blonde hair
yeah me the dad yeah prison or the gay
brother no ha ha ha ha ha look I mean I
might be the in the proud of yourself
you're right I'm gonna run with it yeah
oh that [ __ ] it's just part of my
journey I'm the real Cinderella made
exactly there you go two different just
Cinderella I think would be that movie
Cinderella well Cinderella man no
Cinderella yeah let's just stop my
favorite yeah what do we have here we
got a video question here for you
alright alright hey Mike big fan here
Mike when you knocked out Luke Rockhold
I think that was one of the greatest
moments in UFC history man my questions
for Mike when you were DJing what kind
of events did you do and what were those
bangers that you dropped a breath yeah
she ate it read this jockey
I was yeah it was a professional DJ for
years yeah really add like it like a
nightclub DJ yeah like did you also do
like weddings and dances nah nothing
like come on yeah I swear to god no so
so I was obsessed with martial arts and
then I went I was walking home from one
of the wild dude I was walking on from
one of the shitty dead-end jobs that I
had yeah and I went popped into my
friend's house and he had a set of
turntables and records and stuff and we
were into dance music and I just thought
that was the coolest stuff [ __ ] I've
ever seen in my life and like what kind
of music was like you know house music
yeah house music techno stuff like that
and we were all heavy heavy into it over
there you know and yeah I bought a set
of decks and I just I'm kind of all or
nothing I'm very obsessive from doing
something I just submerged myself into
that and that's what I did and I
I gave up martial arts and I wanted to
be a DJ yeah and you know I was I was
doing alright you know DJ Mikey B that
was my name but now what was something
like now would you play a couple of
tracks to kind of get people to like you
know I I don't know I don't know but he
sold a bit of love going on in the
distance when you drop on a certain
track know the place where I deejay bro
they were hardcore that breaks bugs you
know what I mean so you have Marsh
pinning and stuff you ever see that mosh
pits just people dancing their [ __ ]
asses remain but Seth so I'm doing that
for a long time and then I kind of came
to the realization that I'm not gonna
make it big time I'm not gonna be one of
these guys getting twenty thirty
thousand first set you know what I mean
yeah I was doing I was just about making
enough money to live but it was fun
fortunately when I decided I wanted to
be a fighter I was able to train all
week and DJ at the weekend and just
scrape by enough money to be able to pay
the bills and not get the house
repossessed and all that type of stuff
yeah until was fighting sorry making
money you know what I mean but and we do
were you fighting like a beat in the
beginning if I hit you like that like
punching and stuff no no I just ate
calcu nobody knew nobody knew like that
that I was like this one club i DJ that
was like it was it was a very well
respected dance club but a place was it
was sketchy man it was you guys who like
something straight out of a Guy Ritchie
movie so cuz it was an all-nighter so
what the doorman would finish work at
2:00 but then they got a mom rolls
afterwards to pie so just full of
doormen and gangsters and drug dealers
and all that kind of [ __ ] the [ __ ] that
went on that Club will make your head
spin
I've seen guys come in with samurai
swords and jack guys off
I met swear to god I'm standing by the
front entrance chatting away that's a
Korean name and everyone just started
[ __ ] stampeding out the club and I'm
like what is going on and then I look
and I see a guy with a balaclava and a
samurai shun just storming out the club
like that I'm not holy [ __ ] and he just
hacked someone up on the dance floor did
he lay his tab though the fire exits
with the samurai sword
yeah and in another time yeah terrible
[ __ ] well he probably knew the doorman
but another time because they to do two
sets I do like a set from that two to
three yeah and then another set for my
sixth or 7 a.m.
try to have a few hours in between and
we just hang out do whatever and I went
back to do my second set yeah and my
records have been stolen back then I was
like that they were my pride and joy all
right yeah cuz a lot of the music was
hard to get you know very rare and
whatever and they were my babies my
records man they've been [ __ ] stolen
but as a sound I used to keep myself to
myself and people didn't know that I was
a fighter or whatever do you know what I
mean the rifle [ __ ] said take
Maccabees records [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
took my records and I was fuming so I
went outside onto the carpark and I was
growing up to have the car Am I yo open
your trunk open you boo that's what
quite an England up when you boot I want
to chat in that what voice I'm a records
I've installed open your [ __ ] boot did
open it up and say okay not that so pal
I had to check next time and I went
through a few I went through a few cars
I get to this one car that's it then
guys sitting there smoking a joint I
said yo open the door as I open the boot
is that can't do that
I said dude listen my [ __ ] records
have been stolen alright I just want to
check you boot open the boot is that I
can't do that I said well now you've
gotta [ __ ] do it
it goes alright relax it said I open my
boot easy but when you see what's in
there you gotta shut the [ __ ] up but I
know what it was alright was it a tiger
I said alright whatever
open the [ __ ] boot you [ __ ] but
he gets up he opens a boot there's a
[ __ ] guy in there tied up with a gag
on ankles tied holy [ __ ] dude she slams
it down and I said I haven't got your
[ __ ] records bro am i okay I guess
you haven't Reuben are you that guy in
that boot I don't know I don't want any
part of that [ __ ] might [ __ ] those
records real take him you good I never
liked him anyway was a pretty awesome
man there was a been awesome huh no it
wasn't that the guy looks scared like
they were playing hide-and-go-seek okay
how'd it go she ate as I say you know
didn't look like a sexual thing or they
were just like wasn't this maybe it was
a you know what I like to think it was
essential yeah I like to think it was
it's okay that's just how they got off
you know or dispute I asked you in an
extra dynamic oh we're gonna crazy skid
ed wants his records back this is
role-playing I've never seen this before
it's like Teddy man get in the trunk
shines good so yeah I never had it I
never had any uh
no and that's one of many unfortunately
and that's that's why I had to get out
of that life you know oh yeah it doesn't
you know two years later it's you in the
trunk or at you in the driver's seat
probably one of the other exactly you
know so uh so yeah you know I had to
make a better life for myself yeah which
is again what I did do you sometimes Oh
is a part of you like I mean obviously
you know you've now you've you know
you've gotten to a level in life that
you know few people get to get to and
and that's you know that's just the way
that life has folded out right that's
just the way that it is do you look back
kind of uh fondly on like your youth do
you miss some of the grittiness of it to
you yeah very much so very much I mean
listen you know I do like that never
leaves out of me yeah yeah you know I
mean they say you can take the boy out
of Cleveland all week on set the
Clitheroe out of the boy or whatever you
know same telling you out of Louisiana
but contact Louisiana out of you
oh yeah yeah yeah I mean I loved where I
grew up you know I loved it it was a
beautiful place it really is and I miss
the people I missed a sense of humor
I miss England everyday I really do but
we've built a good life here we've got
three children
we're happy here you know but yeah I'm
missing 'land every day I always say
that I'd moved back in a heartbeat I say
to my wife to piss her off
you know but I wouldn't I don't think I
would be the children are in school here
my wife she moved around a lot her
father was in the military
she moved around a lot she moved to
England when she was 16 she's Australian
and she met me and then we moved here so
she's hypersensitive not to do the same
thing to the kids you know what I'm
saying we took them away from the
friends and family seven and a half
years ago now they've settled they've
got friends they've got girlfriends you
know my girlfriend yeah he's got he goes
to college next year we can't do that to
them you know even though I miss it and
you know our lives here now was um I
went to RAF Alconbury winter
are a couple of different bases okay
that are like around uh around London
like doing some military shows okay nice
I would join air for joint joint basis
yeah yeah I'm pretty very cool yeah yeah
some stuff like that does your does your
son use you as a tool to get women you
know what I think my son Callum
he's a great kid he's a fighter right
he's a boxer no he's restless arrested
number four ranked wrestling in the
state of California so yeah he's doing
great
no I easy to beat some of these guys in
California dude but there's tougher kids
I don't know what they say California is
one of the toughest States because most
of them you guys separate the states
California don't do that oh wow oh yeah
everyone says everyone know he doesn't
usually I think if anything he kind of
pretends that he's not my son I think he
finds me very embarrassing you know what
I mean either that right now there's a
few colleges like reaching out to him
you know for him to be on the wrestling
team yeah attend that college and stuff
and I'm like yeah yeah okay let he's
like no I'll handle this
cuz he thinks I'm gonna go in and like
be the overbearing [ __ ] like Brett
embarrassing dad right you know and take
over the situation but no I really want
but still give are you pretty proud of
him oh very proud he's such a great kid
he really is never had to discipline him
good grades captaining the wrestling
team he's just a great kid steady
girlfriend yeah very proud of him he's
nothing like me
growing up really for it off no I was a
nightmare took me a long time to grow up
I was a nightmare if you were you until
last year I've only just grown up
finally got my [ __ ] together if you were
your son man well it would it become way
to be tough to raise you you think you
mean if my if I was God
yeah be nightmare I don't know at you
because I wasn't a bad kid right I
wasn't a bad kid just the environment I
was in you know I mean yeah I I went
through I mean we do five years of high
school in England Jesus it's not four
six one but I said I said that once on
Fox I said I did five years of high
school and the Karen Brian thought I'd
been held back a year oh my god five
years of high school yeah that's just
what we do here but I did five years
without doing any homework pretty much
that I do any homework once
that wanted you out no it's not because
I was proud of it just my home life
wasn't conducive getting down and that's
quite a place and doing your [ __ ]
homework she told me it wasn't that type
of gaffe you know like at my house my
son could sit down nice and peaceful
complication he'll walk up I put my hand
on his shoulder do you need any
assistance on and he's like no I'm good
I got this dad okay I give him like a
glass of milk
it's very homely with the log fire
crackling I say well I'm here if you
need me son how do you and I walk away
my house no not so much it was a lot of
milk Mellie was no it really wasn't
I can imagine no it's different it's
different is it um is it alarming as you
cuz like you know my family came from
from some similar kind of type of
environments just like hostile home life
right a lot of my family like you know
people from our family deal with like
addiction and stuff like that and if
struggle with that kind of thing
but then I noticed that as people from
my family start having children like
their children's lives are a lot calmer
and a lot yeah is it is it rewarding to
give your kids out life is it almost
kind of like you feel like you're
worried that the kids are gonna have it
too easy like that's one thing I worry
about I'm worried about like if I'm
successful and then my kids are gonna
grow up in a plush environment and
they're gonna be the people that I used
to not be able to stand
yeah ya know for sure I do hear what you
say in that prime example just recently
I'm trying to give my children some
money like no we're good dad I'm right
here did he add lemon 320 Bush says no
that I'm good and then it dawned on me
my how spoiled are these little
[ __ ] I'm trying to force $20 on
the under let no we don't need it I've
got 260 in my room I'm fine that keep
your measly 20 I'm like who are these
children but now the great kids they are
I'm very I'm very very proud of them I
am um do you where do you keep the title
bill ma'am there's one in the regiment
podcast just in the background and
there's one I think in another part of
the house somewhere in the cabinet or
something getting dusty I'm not that
type of guy I don't have like a sheet I
know bells just laying around there was
a few worthy of a podcast bought um like
this guy I know does like real good
artwork and he went through a phase of
sending every time he did one of me yeah
you know it's said one to me because he
was selling them I didn't mind I thought
it would cool and the fan
pieces of our and he sent me tons over
the years and I've got like and they're
[ __ ] huge one section in the car my
house I've got like 30 portraits of
myself do you know like well you can't
put them on the wall I'm not I do sit
down look at all that's really good
imagine somebody walks in and there's
like you know images of yourself all
over the place it's a little bit much
yeah so I'm not that guy so yeah I don't
know maybe it's proper to open a door
somewhere the tile about do you look at
it like like that you with you see the
Bell like do you miss it you look at it
fondly do you look at it and why does it
even seem like your life sometimes I
think that's one thing that's
interesting like I look back yeah it's
like sometimes now when I sit and watch
fights I think it's crazy but then I
think [ __ ] I used to do that and I used
to think nothing of it I thought nothing
I thought was the most natural thing in
the world cuz I just been a fire in my
entire life you know I was always
getting into fights so you just saw
natural but now I've stepped away from
it a little bit and then I sit there and
I watch and I see you know two guys
engaging in a really tough fight there's
a lot of blood on this far I think wow
these guys are [ __ ] crazy man they're
nuts too for doing this yeah but then
but when you involved in it you don't
see it like that yeah see like that I
saw yeah what do you think about do you
think Poirier Diaz will happen or no
they should do I mean they're contracted
to fight I mean who knows I mean Diaz
he's a he's a crazy car is him so Wow
I met his brother one time and it was
pretty fascinating one of the most
interesting guys have met or been around
can I run to the bathroom and we
continue this conversation yeah I'll do
10 minutes when you get back and we'll
be done all right sweet excuse the
interruption here guys I you know in
case you don't want to be a professional
fighter and you want to learn a
different skill well you can go to
Skillshare skill share it's an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more you can take classes in social
media marketing data science mobile
photography and creative writing you
name it they've got it whether you're
just trying to deepen your professional
skill set or whether you're trying to
change the game
you know maybe your wife comes home and
next thing you know you got a new skill
a little bit of CPR or something Manya
Skillshare can help you learn and thrive
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners
that's right
get two months of Skillshare for just 99
cents think about all the skills
that's just 99 cents Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
20,000 classes for just 99 cents go to
Skillshare dot-com slash Theo again that
Skillshare comm slash Theo and learn
something classy since he's American man
yeah hi so are you I know
hate to break it to you super sent me to
I answer how are you really not
sensitive I can be I get I get accused
of that sometimes you know I'm pretty
hard to offend to be honest but if I get
a bee in my bonnet I can be like do you
get like I knew it you know do you get
agretti round like is it that service
isn't quick enough like what kind of
thing gets no no generally I'm very very
happy-go-lucky I feel like I'm of
children say I'm a wife says how I mean
yeah now one again just sometimes the
stupidest thing right yeah this thing
but I try and work on that I read a book
the sort of not giving a [ __ ] oh yeah
it's a great book the sort a lot of not
giving a father
the solo lot the subtle subtle arts are
not giving a [ __ ] yeah it's good book
check it out yeah yeah basically the
what they say is you've only got so many
[ __ ] to give yeah so why would you give
it over over there bad service or
whatever save you [ __ ] stupid questions
on a podcast save your folks there it is
yeah now it's a really good book where
it helped me a little bit you know but
ya know I'm pretty good I'm pretty chill
for the most people like um I mean you
cuz you love to get in a verbal just you
know spatter people it's fun you love
trash talking huh yeah I enjoy a good
debate yeah my favorite are the one with
Kobe coming to us pretty much favorite
that God dude he seemed like such a well
here's the thing I mean he
he came on to the Fox panel and you
start abusing everybody up there yeah
anyway be using cam Brian Kenny Florian
all of us you know yes we predicted him
to lose his fight but we that's how job
as analyst someone's gonna win someone's
gonna lose
and he took offense of that and started
throwing [ __ ] at us so of course with
Holland though it's kind of I love it I
love that I'm not great here we go now
the thing is he kind of thrives in that
controversy yeah that's that's the type
of figure he is so in my mind I'm
thinking okay alright this is what he
does this we who loves and this makes
good TV when I'm doing that Fox stuff um
I'm trying to be entertaining people
don't don't necessarily just want
somebody going on this for greed a
little bit I'm [ __ ] bacon being
boring as [ __ ] yeah gonna be
entertaining yeah it's you gotta
entertain on TV mr. okay here we go yeah
Colby Colby will dance with me here so I
went at him a little bit and he went at
me back and for me my mind I'm just
laughing I'm just having a great time
then apparently there was this whole
controversy after was how it was out I
was out of line for like stealing his
mom and I'm like what are you talking
about I think it gave me [ __ ] I'm gonna
give you [ __ ] but that's just who I am
anymore women's sunglasses as well in
that interview with the really women's I
mean come on I never seen me neither me
neither it looked like the woman that
have been in the monocular you you know
yeah um do you but I agree with you I
think it should be more entertaining I'm
not saying it's not entertaining by the
way in case any of those are watching
right but that's what I try and bring to
the table when I do that do you start to
see uh MMA UFC like a lot of these fight
universes but creating more entertaining
characters like you start to see that
becoming more of a fighters or it just
depends well that seems to be the
general narrative these days what people
try and if you're trying to be critical
of the sport they try and say that these
days it's more about being an
entertainer or being a character and
trash talking and all the rest of it and
I don't necessarily agree with that yeah
of course of you know McGregor is the
biggest star that we have in the sport
by far and he's that of that guy he's
that he's that type of character and
some people try and copy that part of me
it works like a callback Ovington he's
that type but I I kind of get the
feeling he
always a [ __ ] talker yeah you know some
people is to try and do it it's not good
you don't want to fake that if that's
your personality great you know be that
guy but just be yourself you know I mean
going out there and trying to fake it
there's nothing worse than that than
someone trying to talk [ __ ] that can't
talk [ __ ] yeah that's all awkward that's
trying to deliver rehearse lines and
then forget what the punch line was it's
painful it's [ __ ] painful if you're
that guy you can't string a sentence
together focus on winning fight okay
because you're not gonna steal the show
a press conference you know and there's
a lot of good guys out there that do it
but there's a lot of guys that just keep
quiet
respectful and delivering the fights so
yeah I don't necessarily see that that's
the way the trend is shifting right you
know I mean there's it depends on all
different types of characters in
different types of characters was there
was there a fight that you always wanted
that you never got mm good question I
mean the fight I always wanted was
Anderson Silva which I did get which I
was very proud of you know I was
supposed to fight Gegard Mousasi in
London and February 27th which is a day
before my birthday and then Christmas
Eve Dana Wyatt calls me I'm thinking
folks Dana White Colin before Christmas
Eve yeah I'm sure it is a Merry
Christmas
yo what's up bro Merry Christmas man
yeah I want to give you a really good
deal on the spike yeah yeah he says hey
you want to fight Anderson Silva I'm
like yeah dude okay cool we've switched
it you're not fighting gay guy you're
fighting Anderson Silva Merry Christmas
I put the final oh [ __ ] my wife's that
what does he want
I'm like I'm fighting Anders and silver
the day before my birthday so yeah I was
super stoked about that one it was a
great fight I won the fight and there
was a bit of controversy in the third
round and my mouthpiece fell out and
went on the floor and as I was trying to
get it you need me in the face split my
face up and all over the place but it
all added to the journey made it fun
fight you know yeah yeah wow man that's
frickin good that's crazy bro I couldn't
imagine dude if somebody would fight me
man I would find so many excuses not to
show ya but exactly like it's horses for
courses
yeah you know you're a stand-up comedian
I mean Jesus Christ that would terrify
me to walk out to a crowd of people I
mean it probably wouldn't if I'm honest
it probably would it's not that hard but
Bret the child can do it dude
I'm sweating out being honest I'm just
being honest but like you know different
people different characters are suited
this different things
ya know so maybe you're not a fire but
there's things you can do that icon you
know yeah just like when I said everyone
has a skill yours is obviously being a
comedian being a great podcast host but
yeah there you go
it's interesting man is there something
else that you want to do you think of
sometimes I mean commentating obviously
at the it seems like from outsider's
perspective and you know my producer
Nick is a huge fan of MMA and of
interview and of UFC and that it's going
that it's going wells or other things
you think about yeah I mean arming or
anything like that you know it's funny
you mention that you know me and my wife
we do dream of one day buying a house
out in the country with some land that
was some horses some chickens growing
some vegetables and I'm at a nice simple
life eventually we will get there
primarily my attention is on my acting
career
yeah I've been hard on that I'm off to
to audition straight after this
beautiful and so yeah I'm working on
that but that again that's a very very
tough business to be in but that being a
tough business and being hard that
excites me yeah do you know what I mean
yeah of course not everyone can get it
and and you know I've done some work and
I've got some work lined up and I'm
doing little bits of here and there but
but that's what I like I like that chase
yeah you know financially I'm okay yeah
I'm pretty stable I'm alright you know
what I mean so I I'm afforded this time
to be able to pursue and to be able to
chase them and and that in in some ways
is replaced the fighting the hunt you
know what I mean trying to get better
trying to learn trying to go to
auditions and smashy trying to get
projects having the meetings the whole
[ __ ] thing you've got a quality it's
not easy it's hard you got a call away
and try and make an impact yeah and I
like that that excites me and that's
what I'm doing so I feel that man you
know when they told me when I came here
in a lot they're like stand-up comedy is
the hardest thing right I'm sure because
I used to work in reality I got here I
was got in a reality television like
just picked out of college right and was
no way and people hated reality TV
people you know a long member that was
like yeah I know for sure I got no Tyler
no talent yeah so I was here and people
were like oh [ __ ] this guy's got a
talent and I was a kid when they kind of
picked me I was a teenager so it was the
show it was called Road rules it was
like a okay looks like I don't know it
it
okay yeah unlike the real world same
company but there was like traveling and
okay so the kids traveling excited just
traveling around living together and
people were like oh man you'll net you
know like these kids don't have any
talent yeah I was like oh I don't have
any talent I was like I'm gonna take the
hardest job you have which you say is
stand-up comedy and I'm gonna [ __ ] do
no way that's how you got into it
I asked now did you want to be a
comedian I was and is that a story that
you just say cuz it fits in and sounds
kind of badass if you will or was it
legit oh okay what's the hardest
stand-up comedy I'm gonna do that I
wanted to I always I was always making
people laugh so I knew I had the ability
yeah do it yeah um but I think that that
fueled me more than anything honestly
yes my chip on my shoulder I'm sorry
this city like you guys don't think you
guys don't know that I have an
underbelly it's powerful yeah that's a
powerful motivator I had that I've had
that my whole life yeah you know even in
the UFC everyone used to write me off
because I was on the ultimate fire yeah
and then I won the army fire and they
were like yeah but he's only here cuz
they want the English market know what I
mean he's got no talent and this and
that and then I lost to Dan Henderson as
you kindly brought up for everybody I
knew like see see [ __ ] this guy he's
terrible and I was like no I'm gonna
show you all I'm gonna I'm going nowhere
I'm not gonna give up and it's the same
thing now the next phase of my life you
know it's about what's next what is now
ya know we'll say the ambition never
dies that's the funny thing it's like
yeah we start thinking now burn De Niro
and King in this saying podcast and it's
like the ambition keeps going it's like
you know you start thinking about what
what if I wanted to write a book or what
if I you know I dream about learning
Spanish and being able to like go back
to Nicaragua in the middle and in
Central America and do show you're like
you know like you just the emotion never
dies 100% the goalposts just moved yes
all it is you know and yeah I had a
great run a benefice when I'm on to the
next phase in life and as you say the
ambition never dies and in fact for me
now it's it's amplified
it's stronger than ever because now
before that was kind of like my failsafe
being a fire you know that came
naturally yeah I was always a fire did
martial arts my whole life I was add
more fights than hot dinners when I was
a kid you know the main I was always
that shape saw me Dennis hot dinners oh
sorry
more hot Dennis was a fighter hot that
is as a hell of a nickname
oh my great Majan Bruce
renouncing him here we have hot dress
yeah foreigners give the wolf eyes and
hot dinners I'll give the league ago
give the USC a couple years hot dinners
will be one of the main attractions I
love that I'm more fast hot Dennis whoa
hot that it was a crazy [ __ ] man
he had more fights than him no more
fighting hot dinners but for now this
phase yeah it's totally new you know do
you know from my town is trying to do
this year no trying to do a podcast
trying to act trying to [ __ ] work on
TV you know what did you learn about
acting like what is something that
surprised you about acting surprised me
and what it's definitely a lot harder
than what people think you know I'm
still learning all the time you know the
main thing is just listening listening
you know to your to whoever you're
acting with and feeding of what they're
actually telling you yeah a long time
you don't do that you don't listen you
just you just waiting to give your line
yeah you know what I mean but you've got
to live in the scene and hear what
they're saying and take it on take that
emotion and then respond with the
correct emotion from yourself because
you've listened to those words and felt
what those words mean to you right as
opposed to just I know after he sees
this sentence I say let's go to the
market exactly you know what I mean and
it took me a long time to figure that
out I guess yeah it's fascinating and I
noticed the less you do it's like you
think actors are doing some what stuff
and really the doing very little yeah no
for sure I mean for me I'm kind of a
hyperactive guy always have been Oh
super hyperactive as a kid so a lot on
the screen everything's amplified here
as well so you like like my acting coach
you like Mike stop moving your movies
all over the place in this stop you know
slow down as well you know I talk fast I
gotta slow it down stop moving around
stop jumping about you know so it's a
[ __ ] working progress but I'm working
hard on it I'm doing all right I love it
man do we have any more questions you we
are there's one quick line all right I
let's do this one and really here's this
is breaking bags from Canada I have a
question for Michael Bisping
so I see your son Callum is a savage at
wrestling I was just wondering do you
think he'll ever compete in MMA or any
of your kids do you think any of them
will compete in MMA
it's a question I get asked yeah he's
gone it's a question I get asked all the
time to count the little count yeah I
always say I fought so that my children
don't have to yeah
excuse me but yeah you fought so that
your kids can play with iPads if they
want to yes exactly but but he's
talented my son's talented he's a great
wrestler and he loves MMA
he's obsessed of MMA like this weekend
I'll be working for Fox and he give us
what's called pop-ups you know so I on
the Wayne show when like the fight walks
out we pump up in a little screen and we
have to give a little nugget of
information you know what I mean and and
it's okay when it's Conor McGregor or
khabib or whoever but when it's like the
guy and the fight pass prelims all the
way down at the bottom but you've never
[ __ ] heard oh yeah like hot-hot then
it's coming out of Clitheroe England
right you've got to have some stats on
him here I'm a very busy man Theo got
time for that [ __ ] so I'm at Callum give
me some Popov good man absolutely
absolutely 20s like dad I don't need it
I'm rich [ __ ] so I am right so he does
he give me on a pump of information at
Suffolk he's obsessed you've ever made
like so he loves the universe he loves
it exactly and so we talked about it a
little bit and I think maybe he'd like
to have a couple of fights just to get
it out of his system
you know what I mean because he loves it
and he's obviously a talented wrestler
which is a fantastic foundation for MMA
but he's a smart kid and I want him to
have you know how to be a lawyer or
something yeah I don't know but you know
what I mean but yeah I mean if he wants
to I'll support him yeah doesn't want to
I'll be very happy as well and you don't
think about that like I mean I've never
had you know I don't have any children
but does it feel like you that a kid
would like that that it affects your
legacy or just the fact of him being you
know your son that's that's the legacy
no no he's his own person he's his own
person sees a person 100 percent he
always husband he's a unique individual
he's column-based being yeah I'm his dad
he's doing it all by himself
yeah I am there in class with him I on
the wrestling mat with him yeah he's
handling [ __ ] himself and he's doing a
very good job is there stuff he's better
at than you well yeah last night when I
put my hand on his shoulder by the fire
and gave in the glass of milk I'm why
would you care for some help with your
homework son
and he says yes that and he said okay
I'm a little bit busy right now cuz I
had no idea what he was talking about so
academics wasn't really my thing and you
know algebra oh that was all [ __ ] so so
nice guys gonna take this call I'll be
right back
that's awesome him um Michael Bisping
thanks so much for joining us oh yeah
yeah
yeah I'm gonna get we got gifts oh this
response to rid you can have it they got
a nice knife in there a wallet really
not now you're putting me to shame on my
podcast we don't do this that's okay you
say no we don't have a bougie set up
like this this is very la we can even
set you up with them as a sponsor rich
is a great sponsor man they're really
really cool very allies they got some
swag equality and give one to kill him
if he wants he ain't gettin [ __ ]
there you go buy his own stuff well
thank you very much yeah he's got money
yeah exactly Theo pleasure but yeah
Cheers Michael man I appreciate him and
thank you so much for being here the
count the champ uh it's been an honor
and we'll see you guys next time
you